hey you never use that memory changing
thing on me have you no why do you why
are you asking okay good huh birdseed
what the hell is this doing here
I you know that's funny I've always
loved birds I mean maybe this is a sign
maybe I should get one what do you know
no no definitely not okay I hate birds
they smell they squawk and once you get
one you're gonna get attached you're not
gonna want to get rid of it I think it's
a bad idea okay fine jeez I don't get a
bird all right that's weird
I just got a comment on a video I don't
even remember posting can you say I love
you look look he's dancing ha ha ha ha
tickle tickle
I had a pet bird and you killed him
dinya Danielle so well anyways like I
would say thank you so much for making
me those pumpkin muffins they were
delicious